bonjour faire une salle massy
merci beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin
avec nous sur arte france emmanuel
macron hier en hongrie dernier pays de
sa tournée européenne avant sa prise de
fonction à la présidence de deux lieux
comment a été perçu cette cette visite
parlée par les hongrois
évidemment la hongrie est un pays très
polarisée vous savez il ya d'un côté les
adversaires de victoire à bad est
d'autre part ses partisans et donc on a
pu voir deux interprétations à cette
visite tout d'abord pour les partisans
de viktor orban c'est la preuve que
viktor orban est un dirigeant respecté
en europe qui a une importance et qu' il
est capable de discuter d'égal à égal
avec des présidents importants comme
celui de la france
autrement dit que c'est un personnage
incontournable de la scène européenne
tandis que de l'autre côté pour ses eaux
pour les opposants de viktor orban la
visite des manuels macron est un est un
est un soufflet pour pour viktor orban
puisque le représentant de l'europe
progressiste vient remettre les pendules
à l'heure c'est un peu les deux sons de
cloche qui ont été entendus en anglais
je crois qu'ils sont tous les deux un
peu excessif
la réalité étant que
c'est déjà d'une part tout à fait normal
qui est quand même des rencontres entre
dirigeants européens emmanuel macron
avait prévu de faire une tournée de tous
les pays de toutes les capitales
européennes donc c'est normal que ça
arrive et ce n'est pas parce que c'est
là où il n'y a pas un message
particulier
et ensuite je derniers pays de la liste
un oui tout à fait et emmanuel macron a
profité pour faire un tir groupé
d'ailleurs pour voir tous les dirigeants
du v4
mais il a aussi une discussion à part
avec viktor orban donc bon on peut
l'interpréter de d'un certain nombre de
façons c'est certain que
je pense qu'il est aussi question de
calendrier c'est à dire que
discuter et que le v4 avec la hongrie
pour emmanuel macron c'est aussi
important du point de vue de la du
nouveau gouvernement allemand il ya un
certain nombre de choses sur lesquelles
emmanuel macron le groupe de visegrad
peuvent coopérer au niveau européen en
particulier face à l'allemagne dirigée
aujourd'hui par paraît coalition
socialiste vert et du coup à un
président français à la tête de l'ue
heures on le rappelle emmanuel macron de
prendra ses fonctions le 1er janvier
c'est bon un bon signe moins mauvais
signe pour la hongrie
en même temps c'est un bon et un mauvais
signe c'est à dire que si vous voulez il
ya lisons ils ont évoqué très clairement
il ya eu pour quiconque sait décrypter
un peu le langage politique hier ils ont
été assez clair il y a des points de
désaccord très clair très nette en
particulier les questions du
conditionnement des fonds européens à
l'interprétation de la question de
l'état de droit par exemple mais il ya
aussi les points de convergence réelle
encore une fois comme je disais en
particulier face à l'allemagne sur la
question du nucléaire tout d'abord qui
est le choix stratégique qui a été fait
et par la france et par les pays du
visegrad et mais il ya aussi la question
la défense européenne ou encore c'est
moins évoquée mais aussi la question de
l'agriculture est-ce que sur la défense
européenne la hongrie est d'accord avec
le projet d' emmanuel macron de
construire davantage une une défense
européenne
si vous voulez la hongrie n'est pas un
pays qui a
c'est un petit pays c'est un pays qui
naquit à une armée assez réduite qui est
limitée par les traités dans l'armée
qu'elle peut constituer d'ailleurs donc
l'otan
est quand même un outil fondamentalement
américains et pour la hongrie souvent
s'est présenté comme un moindre mal qui
un système de défense européen puisque
ça diminuerait la dépendance à l'otan en
réalité c'est en tout cas une
interprétation qu'on peut faire pour la
pour les angles il est préférable
d'avoir des coopérations militaires plus
local plus régionale il ya également la
question de l'immigration et les deux
hommes se rejoignent
alors là c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
interpréter assez librement à mon sens
non à mon sens c c on ne peut pas
comparer les politiques migratoires ou
même la ti des deux hommes je ne
permettrais pas de dire ce que chacun
d'entre eux dans la tête mais mais je
crois que c'est pas du tout comparable
alors à mon avis du côté de macron il ya
probablement eu un certain nombre de
deux signaux envoyés à un électorat
peut-être plus à droite qui tentait de
reconquérir avec avec un durcissement en
apparence sur sur la question migratoire
mais enfin c'est complètement
incomparable avec la politique
migratoire de victor van je suis
toujours un peu surpris de cette
comparaison pour être honnête dernière
question feirense almaci le président
emmanuel macron va être président de
l'union européenne le 1er janvier ici en
france il ya une certaine polémique
parce qu'ils se serviraient justement de
cette présidence pour faire campagne
est ce que c'est une crainte aussi
partagés au niveau des pays européens
tels que la hongrie qu'il y ait un
mélange des genres finalement
la campagne électorale française n'a pas
vraiment d'importance du point de vue
hongrois évidemment ce qui est plus à
craindre c'est que peut-être que dans le
cadre de cette campagne ils fassent du
zèle ou tentent d'être trop démonstratif
et donc de précipiter certaines
précipite et peut-être certaines
certaines démarches ou certaines
certaines actions donc ça oui peut-être
qu'il y à il ya une certaine crainte ça
reste quand même très relatif c'est que
c'est pas tant la campagne
présidentielle qui inquiète que tout
simplement la présidence française à un
moment où la hongrie et la pologne en
particulier attendent
un jugement sur cette question de la
conditionnalité des fonds européens à la
question de l'état de droit qui est
éminemment une question politique
puisque le la définition d'état droit
n'a jamais été vraiment clarifier c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas
un élément objectif de
ccc basée sur des critères qui n'ont
jamais été établis de manière très
claire est en tout cas accepté de
manière unanime
à partir de là c'est quelque chose dont
qui est le fruit d'une heure d'une
interprétation et donc le fruit d'une
vision politique c'est pour ça que
l'état en bonne part de chantage
politique sur cette question de l'état
de droit merci beaucoup feirense almaci
pour votre éclairage ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes rédacteur en chef du
vide grave poste